welcome to the man of recaps this is
stranger things season four welcome back
to hawkins indiana it's the late 80s and
our adorkable kids have grown up into
high school freshmen tonight they're
playing dungeons and dragons with their
new d d group the hellfire club their
dungeon master is new character eddie
munson a super cool heavy metal
non-conformist but their party's down a
man tonight because lucas has joined the
basketball team so for his replacement
they bring in his younger sister the
adorably precocious erica tonight is the
climactic final battle with the big bad
of their campaign the archlich vechna
dnd and basketball both come down to the
sinclair siblings and yeah nat 20 in the
hoop wow
but meanwhile there's trouble in hawkins
the cheerleader chrissy is being haunted
by a creepy clock she tries to buy some
pot from eddie hoping that might help in
fact she goes back to his trailer to get
the harder stuff but then she goes into
some kind of trance where she's living a
horror movie and being haunted by the
whole super creepy dude as he grabs her
she starts floating and kills her in a
disturbingly brutal way living next door
to eddie is our friend max and that
night the lights went crazy like some
upside down shenanigans so max brings in
dustin who knows that he's innocent but
the rest of the town like chrissy's
basketball boyfriend jumps to the
conclusion that he killed her in a
dungeons dragon satanic ritual to help
find eddie and clear his name they bring
in their other teenage friends steve
harrington and robin now working at the
video store their best lead is eddie's
dealer reefer rick so they search all
the rick's video rental histories and
find the one with eddie hiding in his
boathouse they give him the recap of
seasons one through three like what was
it demogorgon mindflayer but this was
something different a dark spellcaster
who attacked with a curse and so we have
our name for this season's villain it's
vecna and our party's strongest member
is not here to help because eleven moved
to california with the buyers family
she's having some trouble fitting in in
fact these kids are downright cruel and
remember 11 lost her psychic powers last
season they still haven't come back but
now it's spring break and her boyfriend
mike flies out to visit her as well as
his best friend will will's older
brother jonathan has become a california
stoner with his new best friend argyle a
hilarious caricature of a human being
jonathan was supposed to go to hawkins
to visit his girlfriend my sister nancy
wheeler but they've been having some
long-distance issues the main thing is
they're supposed to go to college
together but jonathan doesn't think he's
going to go he's got to stay with his
family and hasn't told her yet speaking
of his family his mom joyce byers gets a
mysterious package from russia a ransom
note for hopper yes she thought he died
last season when they blew up the
machine but oh what's this he ran
through the portal and woke up in the
other one over in russia so joyce calls
up murray their hilarious ridiculous
russian-speaking friend who's good at
this kind of thing they talk to enzo a
guard at the prison camp hopper
befriended who can get him out for the
right price so they head to alaska to
bring the ransom to the hilariously
annoying russian smuggler yuri hopper
puts in a ton of work for his epic
escape but yuri betrayed them and now
they're all back in prison now back in
hawkins the gang's trying to figure out
who vetna's next victim will be and bad
news it's one of our own cause max is
seeing clocks investigative journalist
nancy wheeler finds out this murder was
just like the old victor creel murders
yeah he went crazy and murdered his
family but he always claimed a demon did
it so nancy and robin go undercover and
meet the man himself victor creel they
get his story of how he moved into this
haunted house and yeah sure sounds like
it was becna meanwhile max is reading a
letter to her dead brother billy she
feels guilty about his death because
remember he was a bad brother she used
to wish he would die but now he kind of
redeemed himself and she feels bad and
turns out that type of guilt and trauma
is exactly what vekna feeds on oh no
he's got her they check in with the
girls who have something that might help
victor creel himself survived when his
favorite song came on the radio so they
pop a tape in the walkman just in time
as vekna's got her oh she's floating but
now kate bush starts singing and running
up that hill and the window to the
outside world opens and max runs for it
it's an epic beautiful cinematic
masterpiece scene if i could make a deer
with gerd and boom yes max makes it out
she survives and kate bush soars back to
the number one spot on the charts you're
a kate bush fan
uh yeah
now i am meanwhile in california mike
and eleven having a great spring break
with uh will as their third wheel later
will and mike have a real heart to heart
where it's like sorry i've been ignoring
you man it's just you know i got a
girlfriend now will has a secret that's
making him sad it's heavily implied he
is gay which is a hard thing to be when
the world's not accepting but the
bullies show up and are just so mean for
no reason why are kids so awful eleven's
had enough she clocks this girl in the
face and was totally justified but the
cops show up and arrest her but wait
it's not the real cops it's the good
c.i.a dr owens unfortunately bad
government guy thinks 11 is the killer
so dr owens is here to save her and
turns out he's got a thing where he can
maybe get her powers back he takes her
to the super secret off the books
project nina and guess who else is
working here it is dr brenner yeah papa
yes he survived the demogorgon attack
and now apologizes for being kind of a
bad dude so they put her in the psychic
pool where she can relive memories of
her younger self back at the hawkins lab
that she blocked and looks like it's
gonna work she starts to get her powers
back now they fill in her friends and
put them under house arrest for their
own protection but they make a plan to
escape by ordering a pizza from their
new friend argyle but wait what's this
that's not the pizza boy oh bad
government found him and random agent
guy goes into beast mode to save these
kids luckily pizza's here for the
getaway car just in time they got the
number to the nina project but it's not
a phone it's a computer so they go on a
road trip to an expert computer hacker
dustin's girlfriend susie she helps him
out with some 80s hacking and now
they're off to save 11. but back in
hawkins the gang's investigating the old
creel house to look for answers max had
been distant from her friends and broke
up with lucas but now these two get back
together and remember steve and nancy
used to date he's a much better guy now
and she's feeling distant from jonathan
will they rekindle a little flame but
now their flashlights start going off
and they realize this is vecna's home
base in the upside down and beckham is
attacking someone right now because the
basketball kids finally found eddie
they're swimming out to catch him but
one of the guys is [ __ ] as the next
victim and oh he kills him right there
now dustin has a theory that at the site
of each murder bekna opens a gate to the
upside down so steve harrington dives in
the lake to see what's down there and oh
yeah it's a gate and our vine grabs him
and steve is in the upside down now the
upside down is not a happy place in fact
it's filled with killer bats but the
other teenagers followed him here they
do some bat smashing unfortunately now
their exit is blocked they're stuck here
they go to nancy's house to grab her gun
but wait it's not here and pretty soon
they realize this bizarro version of
hawkins is stuck at the beginning of
season one the younger kids have
regrouped at the real wheeler house and
sound travels from that one they can
kinda hear them but can't talk back so
they pull the season one trick that will
buyers figured out they can make the
lights flicker they don't have christmas
lights on hand but they do have a light
bright so our gangs are able to
communicate they meet up at eddie's
trailer that now has a portal on the
ceiling and so it's a true upside-down
cross-dimensional traveling but vechna
realized they're here and gets nancy but
meanwhile eleven's gonna unlock her main
memory the bad one of a massacre at
hawkins lab long story short there was a
nice tech that worked there that was
gonna help eleven escape but first he
needed her help to get the tracking chip
out of his neck but oh it wasn't a
tracking chip it was a power suppressor
he's psychic too in fact he's number one
and he's not just trying to escape he
also killed all the other kids he's got
a whole philosophy that doesn't make
sense he's just a psychopath meanwhile
nancy's in a vector trance and he shows
her the creel story from the point of
view of the son henry it turns out the
house wasn't haunted he had psychic
powers and killed his family and he
ended up at the hawkins lab became
number one and so when eleven had to
fight him without knowing how she
banished him to the upside down but he
didn't die there he embraced it and
became vachna he can't kill nancy here
he just shows her his plan which as you
might expect is to open a monster portal
and turn the whole world into the upside
down he only needs four kills to do it
and he's already done three so one more
and the world is doomed they gotta go
back down there and kill him but they
have to wait till he's distracted
attacking his next victim and i know
when he wants max will be the bait but
there's good news cause 11's powers are
fully back oh yeah we're in business
they fill her in about hawkins and vekna
she's like i gotta go back there and
help my friends but dr brenner's like yo
you're not ready and he stages a coup
gonna keep loving here as a prisoner
again and eleven realizes hey papa
you're the real monster but just then
bad government gets there it's a big
shootout papa's running with eleven and
oh papa down eleven's gonna be next but
wait what's that did someone order a
pizza yes elavin's friends are here to
rescue her by the distraction she needed
to blow up this helicopter and eleven
and mike reunited they gotta go help
their friends in hawkins tonight but
it's just not physically possible to get
there so levin has an idea if beckham
goes in max's mind she can piggyback in
there too so they set up base at surfer
boy pizza which has everything they need
for a sensory deprivation tank the
adults meanwhile are on their own wild
adventure being kidnapped to russia but
joyce breaks the peanut butter and
murray's learned karate they don't know
how to fly the plane though so it
crashes luckily murray and yuri look
enough alike he's able to fool him and
they get into the prison where they find
hopper but what's this behind that door
they're getting ready for a fight with a
demogorgon oh an og season one monster
this thing's a beast luckily hopper
stole a lighter and is able to hold this
thing off just long enough for them to
open the gate and he gets out of there
and so joyce and hopper are reunited
while they're trying to find a ride back
to america turns out hopper has been on
that russian gulag diet dang hop looking
good and he and joyce finally get it on
but they're interrupted by a call from
the good cia who fills them in on the
whole thing and how their kids are in
danger they can't get back to hawkins
tonight but there's a way they can help
from here because while they were
escaping the russians had here a piece
of the mind flayer so they're gonna
break back into the prison and torch
that thing because it's all connected
maybe give their kids an edge so our
hawkins gang is all geared up to take
the fight to vecna in the upside down
max thinks bad thoughts which gets him
after her but then she thinks good
thoughts where she's able to hide in
those memories the older teens go to
beckham's house but it's guarded by an
army of bats luckily they've got a plan
for that they need a distraction to lure
them out and they've got one in the form
of eddie munson putting on the most
metal concert of all time in an
alternate dark dimension ripping
metallica yeah
so the bats fly away and our game goes
in but there's another defense system
here the vines that don't know i mean
they get them and eddie's trailer is not
as bad proof as they thought eddie's
gotta lead him out of there and then
it's time for an epic final stand
things go bad in the real world too as
basketball guy finds max in lucas and
thinks lucas is sacrificing her to the
dungeons of dragon's devil so these two
have a big fight and max can't hold
beckham off forever oh he's in there but
oh what's this someone's here to help
yes eleven coming in from the pizza shop
piggy back she and becna have their
psychic fight and she's real strong but
he knows his powers better and now we
learn a missing piece of his backstory
because when she banished him here the
upside down was a slightly happier place
till one day he discovered the mind
flayer just chilling in its natural
habitat now we had assumed the
mindflayer was the big boss and beknow
was possessed by it it's five star
general but it's not the mind flare who
possessed vacna it was vecna who
possessed the mind flare bent it to his
will and he is the true big bad of the
upside down so now he's got max and
things are looking bleak 11 can't escape
but mike comes in with the epic pep talk
and boom 11's out of there trash is this
guy simultaneously in russia things are
looking bleak but murray with the
flamethrower oh damn a dog barbecue
because vector's mind is in all of them
that really hurts he starts to drop
control so our game gets into his
undefended body and blah lights him on
fire boom
also hop found a sword and his sword
fighting a demogorgon so it's an epic
final climax where it cuts off the head
and out the window but his body
disappears so it's not over yet and poor
eddie munson dies from the bat wounds no
he was so great but wait it gets worse
because they were too late to save max
she was too wounded and it's
heartbreaking as she dies in lucas's
arms and so after all that beckner got
his fourth kill all four portals opening
up huge converging right in the center
of hawkins nothing else happens though
no immediate apocalypse so it's just a
big earthquake life goes on and as our
friends are returned to hawkins it's
happy reunions all around jonathan and
nancy you reaffirm they're still dating
sorry steve although he doesn't tell her
about the college thing yet so it's all
still open but then there's a sad
reunion because max is alive but in a
coma eleven was there in her mind when
she died and was like no i can use my
powers to save you and it kind of worked
she is alive but may never wake up but
then there's the happiest reunion of
them all as hopper comes home eleven
finds out her adopted dad's alive but in
the upside down vecna is wounded but not
defeated it starts to rain the iconic
ash of the upside down and indeed if you
check out these portals they're spewing
it into the atmosphere the upside down
is coming so our heroes prepare for the
final showdown and that's where stranger
things season 4 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]